[Musique]
les acteurs publics les élus et les
représentants d'entreprises se sont
donnés une journée pour débattre et
établir une stratégie fonctionnelle afin
d'ouvrir les marchés publics aux tpe et
pme de la règle la méthode
opérationnelle et la stratégie du bon
achat ou quand les tpe/pme prennent de
plus en plus de parts de marchés publics
la stratégie de rachat c'est huit années
où on a pris le temps de se connaître on
après tant de comprendre les enjeux
respectifs
il a pris le temps d'arriver au résultat
optimal qui est le développement de la
réunion par les réunionnais parce que
parfois il est arrivé que la raison se
développer mais sans nous
donc l'idée n'est pas de dire que petit
des préférentiels parce qu'il n'ya pas
de petit s'il n'y a pas de petits
patrons il n'y a pas de grands patrons
des grands entrepreneurs et la démarche
de la stratégie de la chasse et faire
comprendre ça aux collectivités que
quand ils achètent ils créent des
conditions de développer par des grands
entrepreneurs la réunion dès 2010 le
département de la réunion s'engage dans
la convention du sb à et favorise ainsi
un accès équitable des tpe pme à ces
marchés publics
91 % de ces offres sont attribués à des
entreprises locales
oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui la place du
département
et très importante quand on sait que le
département se travailler plus et plus
de 1600 entreprises 2,9 avec un
investissement qui avoisine on va dire
les 180 millions d'euros ainsi on
rajoute encore une fois les les 130
millions de propre au département plus
les 64 accordés aux communes dans le
cadre de ce de marché triennal donc
forcément le département a toute sa
place
dans cet espace la simplification des
démarches administratives la
dématérialisation les allotissement
autant de mesures qui rendent plus
accessibles les consultations des
marchés publics
les entrepreneurs profite de cette
journée pour aller à la rencontre des
collectivités alors là on vient chercher
vous des informations des renseignements
sur comment traiter une demande du big
grenier pour essayer justement d'entrer
dans le dans le domaine de se développer
les acteurs de cette journée ont
conscience des ambitions affichées par
le fbi à relancer l'économie
réunionnaise faire baisser le taux de
chômage est privilégié un développement
cohérent du territoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]